Бессарабія
Ukraїner. Експедиція
Аккерманська фортеця. Білгород-Дністровський
Найбільша збережена фортеця на території України
Рисові поля. Ліски
Заливні плантації рису вздовж дельти Дунаю приваблюють безліч птахів, риби та черепах
Беджацький лиман. Сергіївка
Чудове місце для любителів яхтингу. Тут проходять змагання з вітрильного спорту
Альтернативна енергія. Старокозаче
Найбільша в Україні кількість великих сонячних електростанцій - саме у Бессарабії
Музей радянського минулого. Фрумушика-Нова
На місці знищеного радянською владою села виставлено зібрані з усієї країни пам'ятники колишнім вождям
Французьке вино. Шабо
Крістоф Лакарен створює справжнє французьке вино з натурального українського винограду
Батьківщина пеліканів. Дунайський заповідник
Бессарабія - батьківщина найбільшої в світі популяції сірих та рожевих пеліканів. Звідси вони літають до Африки на зимівлю
Місто на воді. Вилкове
Мешканці Вилкового віддавні пересуваються каналами замість вулиць, човнами замість авто
Оператор: Павло Пашко. Монтаж: Микола Носок. Музика: Omodada